yo man bootleg head podcast
we got the special guest man the homie
fredo bang is here be me that won't rock
and read on the reason why you baby that
scared the name of tv telling them when
they made no sense to speak
well i don't even know what did what'd
you just say
are those all your akas be me easy like
bang man but
yeah be me
[Music]
wait is is your a r pulling up because
he just called me i
do i have to let him in he might be
called to see if i got here
okay all right cool i think we're good
um yeah shout out to you know
another legendary southern artist with
all the akas would be big boy
big boy from outcast every time you say
his name he'd be like
aka daddy fat sax aka lucious left foot
aka
yo man um it's good to see you though
bro uh i think
last time we saw each other was like
right before [ __ ] got hectic
right before the whole world shut down
march yeah it was like march it was it
was about six seven months ago so like
things have definitely changed um
how have you been adjusting to just the
way the world is now
because i know usually you'd be on the
road right now
grabbing all kinds of brown paper bags
like what's what's been the
the adjustment for you oh i've been
playing the game well
like video games yeah i feel you like me
too i don't know like
i i got an addiction to war zone yo
warzone is um
addictive to say that like it's like you
be in a whole another world i don't care
about my phone i don't
talk to nobody it's just different
yeah that and then i just got the new
tony hawk well not the
the old tony hawk when i was a kid when
i was little yeah so when i was little i
had it
and then they just put out the
remastered version so
i've been just just diving in man head
first that war zone
still uh i hope so yeah tony hawk's
still alive
that would be i feel like i would know
if tony hawk was dead
he was just on joe rogan like last year
i hope he's still alive shout out to
tony hawk
um so you've been playing a lot of video
games obviously you've been working joe
just wasn't
just war zone just sticking on war zone
that's what
uh how are you nice on war zone though
i'm not because i feel like i started
playing it too late
i did but because you know when you play
it too late then you get on and
everyone's so good
playing so i don't got into so yeah i
feel like
i caught the wave a little late because
now like i hop on and it's all these
everyone's so [ __ ]
fine-tuned and good and i'm just like
i'm getting smoked on there bro
was you playing our playstation yeah ps4
what's up i'm about a pc and everything
that's how in tune i got into it
i bought a pc you bought a pc bro yeah
yo that's next level gaming that's like
siri
when you find someone who is a gaming pc
you're like oh yeah you're a real
[ __ ] nerd for sure
you got the graphics card and the
[ __ ] chair and
y'all bought me a chat bought a massage
super ill chair you probably got a
[ __ ] colorful ass keyblade cut key
lighted keyboard you light up
i bet you do how much did you spend on
your gaming
pc uh 15 on it oh yeah that's that's
gonna
that's gonna fly big monitor oh i'm on
the tv oh yeah of course
okay i can't reach it's cross
cross-platform right
like you'll be smoking people who are
playing on other yeah that's just
the thing is when you're on the um when
you're on like playstation stuff like
your timing like a half a second
late so if you're on the pc you got a
half a second advantage
yeah you're like you faster
that's hey that makes sense shout out to
everybody out there playing at uh
warzone but you also have been obviously
extremely productive during the
quarantine uh
it's your second project in a year right
two is it three my third in november
november maybe 12 months so today my
third and 11 months
third and 11 months second of 2020 yeah
damn so
the work ethic is crazy but like
why is it important for you to keep your
feet on like your foot on the neck of
the game right now because i feel like
that's just kind of the way that the
game is now you got to kind of keep
like you just gotta people fans have
such a short attention span you know
what you're saying like you got to keep
dropping
yeah because like fans will write me
like if i don't drop a song in a month
like man you falling off that [ __ ]
like just like i say like dropping
projects back to back and you learn like
what works and what doesn't like
consistency they love consistency so
i'm trying to be consistent as possible
like most of the videos from this
project i shot in a week like i shot
seven videos in one week
[ __ ] that's a lot of video i mean how
many years out right now three or four
i feel like i just saw i mean there's at
least three there's at least three
there's eight already from just the
project all together that are already
out
seven six or seven six that's crazy
so what if you you say you learned every
time you drop a project you learn from
the last time you drop
what have you learned so far that you
applied to this new [ __ ]
um like learning like finesse moves like
more pre-release songs more produce
pre-release streams the better placement
for like apple charts and stuff
you know that all that going to like
when i type you know when i'm somebody
want to look at new music
i was at the top of the charts so you're
kind of figuring out how the
because like you say like a lot of
people don't know instead of you just
dropping out of nowhere
you say you got five songs have been out
running numbers up and so
as soon as your project goes live those
five songs are on there
it it just helps you with your apple
chart it helps you over
is about to drop drop a whole project
that's fresh
yeah unless it's like unless it's like
someone ran like like beyonce or
somebody
someone grew because it's got to be
somebody out of this world and if you
notice like
these new days like those big orders
sometimes like they placement don't be
good
no if they drop it they drop a fresh
project yeah no
like and the other thing too is
obviously everyone's finessing the
and you know i use the word finesse
politely because it's just you got to
play the
other you got to play the rules they
give you you know what i'm saying it's
the game you're playing
but it's the deluxe the deluxe edition
you know you drop the deluxe it's almost
like a whole nother album and then you
just put it all in
it goes towards the sales of the first
project are you going to do a deluxe for
for this album yeah we'll do it for this
one
how many songs do you know how many
songs are gonna be on it on the deluxe
yeah i started to put like 10 or
something but like i don't know
it's hard the only thing hard about
deluxe is
when you got songs working or connecting
you don't want to overshadow them with
the most singles
but that's true i like i take my time
with each and every song so
like every zombie then is special to me
so don't be like just know
throw that on now you know what i'm
saying and you got to make sure
when you do the track listen like that'd
be the last final step of my projects
because i gotta
listen to each song and then i gotta i
want this to go
you gotta put it all together you gotta
get flowing yeah and beginning each beat
like
all my projects like a lot of people
don't do that anymore so well like if
you play it you can sit there and let it
roll and you'll not know that
you just listen to the whole project
talk about your relationship with kevin
gates i know it's a close one gates i
feel like
has always embraced um the younger
generation and
try to you know co-sign certain people
yeah
um how's y'all's relationship how did it
start man oh
my big brother
from the very beginning he didn't like
help me with my career in like ways he
didn't even know like
me and g we had a song called iphone 6
like it's one of our hottest
br songs he shared it to the store like
roses up you know what i'm saying right
just just he always like i don't like he
just always been like motivational like
you know what i'm saying when i was in
jail like
i wrote like when i come home i'm like
i'm getting it like you know what i'm
saying
here write me like right before i can't
pray for me send me a long prayer you
feel me
so he was actually writing you in jail
like he was like
on the phone so you had this did you
have the like phone like
tucked in jail like was it was it was it
contraband or did they know you had it
no it was controversial
how do you get a phone into jail uh
guards
the guard so you just trip the guard off
sort of make sure it's like like
you know not some like you know you've
been seeing some crazy [ __ ] in the
movies yeah yeah
i'm not doing those like you got a girl
who puts shoves it up her ass no they
got people
they got people who do all that but i i
was never that type to put nobody else
like was it a small phone
oh the touchscreen that's
only people let's see me was my girl or
my my mama so i'm not about to put them
in the wrist no of course of course yeah
yeah yeah yeah it ain't worth all that
that's crazy though cuz cuz like i know
being in jail is like
you know i got a lot of family members
that are in prison and they
they live for you know especially if
you're for a long time but just the
the just the letter makes their whole
month you know what i'm saying yeah no
no
like my girl like she used to send
pictures like
a picture just change your whole
week yeah you'll sit there just sitting
there smelling them
like just trying to smell them you feel
me like actual photos
yeah like like like comment please like
share
it in the envelope and subscribe it so i
actually told my girl like the plate
like to touch it and wrote a letter of
course you got to
bro that's that's that's what we like to
call jerk off material
hey when you're in jail like you want
alone time like that and you got a selly
you just be like hey fam
i'm up here with my ladies letter leave
me the [ __ ] alone like
huh gun line what does that mean gun
line
don't cross the gun line oh so you okay
like don't come over here don't come
over here yeah but basically like you
got different
you got different um facilities and
different rules you feeling so like
uh like i know y'all probably used to
sales full man sales or something like
that
if you got like that the shower nine
times the 10 is down on the walk
by itself and with a bathroom it you
know what i'm saying
so you can leave out go do your thing
while you're in the shower you know i'm
saying you got a closed-off shower
now if you in like most of the time i
was in a dawn
with like 200 people 150 people
so everything is completely open
so what you'll have to do is you'll
probably have to like
for one you got to wait till everybody
go to sleep
like late of course three four in the
morning then you gotta like either
put a blanket up or something around the
bathroom you gotta cut off the bathroom
or like put a trash can up or something
call out gun line
so if anybody come back there now they
ain't wrong so if you yell out gun line
everybody knows like yo
don't take it off rubble went out yeah
damn
that's crazy and
did you ever accidentally walk into
someone's gun line situation because you
didn't hear them
no what about you like the opposite
where like someone like uh
like on me like yo man fam i'm over here
trying to handle my [ __ ]
very discreet with mine's like i was the
type like i wait to you everybody go to
child
hey you got the phone in there yeah you
got the internet pornhub popping on that
[ __ ]
i eat i'll wait till everybody go to
lunch ah
or i i used to violate a little bit like
so i take my whole bunk and i
i'll wrap the whole tent up oh [ __ ] so
you just have a whole
like a fort yeah damn that's crazy
yo you're [ __ ] if you ever like
want to write a book like you know like
it'll sell like crazy in jail
like ways to set up your gun line yeah
you could you you'll take the sheet you
you could there's like different methods
you could do the ten you could do the
[ __ ] yeah
my shield caller maybe they're maybach
you take a string
and basically like what they do you take
the string
tie it all the way around the whole um
well it's not a string it's really like
dental floss
okay and you just keep tying it up and
you make it thick
go around the whole bunk so the whole
but you got the on your blankets get it
to where you
get on now and you got to sew it
like a curtain yeah so it slides slides
yeah hey man but you're not supposed to
have a tent up so when the police come
in they'll rip your stuff down so
that's how i made it make like a maybe
so when they come in i just pull both
sides of the curtain all the way back
they don't see it were you able to have
conjugal visits
no that's for people that got life it's
for like forever
yeah how long what's the longest yeah
that's the longest you were locked up
for
two and a half two and a half years and
and during that time
give us the timeline of that and where
you were in your career and how like
when you got locked up were you taking
music serious at the time
not really but we was the hottest in
baton rouge
well really like louisiana so you got
locked up
being like that dude in in your city
and did it take you getting locked up to
like realize like i need to take this
[ __ ]
more seriously it helped yeah definitely
i had i usually had like one time i had
somebody come to jail and get on their
knees
and beg me to rap [ __ ] the weirdest [ __ ]
ever
like somebody who was locked up with you
yeah
i hate the man got on his knees in front
of me and was like please rap for me
i mean in jail that's probably the best
case scenario of someone getting on
their knees
i mean god bless but no um
did you rap or were you like fam you're
[ __ ] weirdo
i was never that type like for me to rap
i gotta be in a good mood and like
sometimes they have some cyphers and
stuff and you jump in
no no i just come just you know what i'm
saying would you like uh
like how much when you got out of jail
did you have like
tons of notebooks full of your lyrics
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah still yeah i got a bunch of wraps i
ain't do
cause i'm in a whole different like i'm
in a whole different like
space with my music you know yeah of
course the content's got to change your
life has changed you're not in that
space anymore like
yeah then that's what some people
problem is like
it's just some some people come home and
they they make jail music you feel me
it's like
nobody wants to i mean it's cool but
it's also like
you gotta you know you also gotta evolve
i feel like it's just the same way with
people like
some artists they're like oh i'm gonna
make it just r b
project i'm gonna just make a rap
project i'm gonna make a sample no i'm
saying like
that's why each of my projects you're
gonna get everything like
yeah for sure i don't wanna just sit you
know i'm saying as soon as you do that
it's like
uh i ain't [ __ ] with that you know
what i'm saying
so next they probably expecting you to
do the same thing you feel me
you were talking about kevin gates
writing you um he's
you know i feel like every time he hangs
out with someone they become muslim for
a few months
did he did he try to get you to you know
uh participate in the uh
in the uh islamic faith oh
i wouldn't i wouldn't say that i
wouldn't say that am i tripping though
or is that true
you'll see people around kevin gates
then all of a sudden
they're muslim and i'm like they must
have been around kevin gates
i'm gonna say his character and and his
energy
makes you want to be involved
with it with it you feel me i'm gonna
say that so i feel like a lot of people
gravitate to his enemies you'll be like
yo i [ __ ] with your energy
and then you associate that with maybe
his his his faith
it's like it's like i'm trying to try to
find a way to put it right you haven't
like noticed like
in history of people that like just have
a like people just gravitate to them
yeah for some reason yeah for sure you
know what i'm saying
like they got that gift he's got that uh
quality for sure you got people who want
to be just like him
yeah so they're going to do things like
him and stuff like that
but when i on i did go to the what is
called the um
mosque i did go i did go there with him
i told him i like i i i'm not gonna do
that
yeah i i just stayed at the door and i
like but i i really liked it
i'm gonna pull up with you you're like
you know i'm saying i'd have been around
it like in jail like
but i'm really strict in my religious
beliefs like what are your religious
beliefs
i believe in god and that's it so you
consider yourself christian
baptist i just believe in i i used to be
baptised but i believe in god
right so no bible like no paper like
it's just you know what that i i respect
it's just simple as that like it's just
like you believe in a higher power
yeah like because when you get into okay
which religion here you know it gets you
you get a headache just thinking about
this well i also think too that a lot of
people
should i i'm personally like i am
atheist but but i feel like i
i i i i really could like see it all you
i really believe in like like if you
told me what's more real
aliens or you know heavens in the sky
i'm [ __ ] running with the alien dog
all day you know what i'm saying
but like personally but you had a right
because like
it's like i want to believe in something
that i can see and i
i ca i can i want to believe in things
that make sense and i feel and and i
feel like
but over the history of our world
religion has been the biggest divider
and it's caused
all the wars right and everybody is not
right and it's man-made
right a lot of these religions they're
all written all these books are written
by i don't believe in man so
i respect that you cannot believe if you
don't believe
everything a human says you cannot
believe in the bible i think that means
that you're
you're agnostic technically you believe
in a higher power you just don't
identify i don't identify
yeah you're spiritual not religious yeah
okay that's fair
because it's like like for one like if
you just if you just
like take little things and just really
pay attention like
slavery right you go to slavery nah
they didn't want us to know how to read
so what they did i'm gonna get this one
person that does know how to read
and i'm gonna make him read you what i
want you to read
not i'm not about to give you what you
need to know
you fear me and that's and what you just
said
so why the [ __ ] would i believe what you
just said to me is
is religious it's religion right it's
it's it's used to
uh control the vulnerable so how we
troll how you used to control society
how do we know that all these religions
wouldn't make
just for that that's what it's for
that's what it's for no it's the biggest
hypocritical horseshit ever like you
know if you think of like
listen man i just i i respect someone
who says they're christian
because like hey whatever makes you
whole at night and you know
but i just think that religion in
general is something that
is very easy to point out clearly the
bad that it's contributed to that i
respect everybody
but like it's just like just like
then like with the muslim thing like i
respect them dudes like
for sure with a lot of me too but a lot
of those people when i was in jail
joined muslim just for protection
like a lot of people like i'm talking
about like they really over here trying
to learn a whole different language
for protection so [ __ ] won't get on the
ass you know you feel me
[ __ ] so wait so were the muslims in your
jail was it like
was it low-key like if you were like a
part of that crew everyone had each
other's back
like uh like oh and what were you locked
up in in
in louisiana yeah okay because you don't
go out of state unless you federal
right right right right but um well i
did do
to some camps out of the state elite but
it's really illegally but
i'll stay [ __ ] up down your [ __ ] right
but um
yeah like some people like like they
will say their mothers in them and their
you know i don't know you know that's
crazy shout out to i mean like i said
man i respect everyone's
viewpoints i just have my own yeah he um
like he he he invited me to i went in
like just uh
because i i hadn't been around it i
haven't been asked
to actual one right right so it was
like i like the experience things you
feel me so it was like a good experience
and stuff
yeah of course that's the
make you be something you know what i'm
saying
it's just people people like gravitate
to his energy he got he got a
the being around him is it's a good fit
like we i don't know if you remember the
moment where he told the interviews to
stop touching him
that was me and dj head's interview
[Laughter]
and it was the most intense like
20 minutes of our life and then after
the interview
it went super viral obviously and we
were like what the [ __ ] just happened
because he just got well he just got out
of jail like six months earlier
but but i'm like he let his guard down
after the interview finished and we
talked for like an hour
he played us his album and he was like
he was like [ __ ] man
if i'd have known y'all were like i wish
i would've known y'all but
like we would've had a much better
interview because i [ __ ] with y'all
cause i'm like that with interviews too
is like
i come like i'm always going to be kind
of hissing to people
like but you make me feel comfortable
okay
it's going to be a good interview well
plus it's also on
you know i think too like i don't [ __ ]
with that touching [ __ ] either though
i didn't my biggest pet peeve is when
you talking to me
and you like yo fam like hey fam yeah
that [ __ ] is like no no i feel it like
like it's just like next dj has to touch
her okay
nah but it's interesting too because we
were just talking off off the cameras
about
you know i can only imagine
how uh irritating it can be
to do a press run and like you got to go
like i know you for the last album you
did a bunch of zoom stuff
and instagram live stuff and it makes it
so much
easier for just anybody because then
because it's not so before you would
have to like go on a promo run to all
these cities
right now it's like everyone's getting
an interview so
so i saw fred o'bane was on ig live with
everybody
and it was like you get the same
questions and then half of these
[ __ ] don't know what they're
talking about they're just asking you
generic [ __ ]
like hey what's it like to work with
mulatto somebody asked me
oh um
somebody asked me some dumbass [ __ ] like
so when the last time
uh ung made a song do you
like do y'all plan on getting in the
studio again like he you know he's dead
i'm like he's dead
that that should have went viral what a
[ __ ]
oh my god that's crazy some people just
being annoyed then like someone like try
to make it seem like you need them like
i'm the type person like you can always
learn from somebody you feel me
but don't make me don't try to belittle
me no i think that um
unfortunately and i try to point it out
as much as i can but like a lot of radio
djs
um have a very distorted version of
reality
and entitlement when it comes to artists
where it's a two-way street
it's like you don't need me
like especially somebody like you like
bro like you got here with no radio you
know what i'm saying so it's like
i just think it's a respect thing man
but yeah man um the new album is crazy i
feel like
you got some joints on here i think you
know the freak record could be some [ __ ]
that could go up
honestly i didn't like it you didn't
like it i had a song i made a song two
years ago
the two-year-old song was was mulatto on
it the whole time did you just put it on
i just put it on
okay okay i don't know i love her verse
i love pizza versus crazy personally
it's just not
it's not your energy yeah it's
definitely
yeah it was just something i wasn't i
was in the studio high as a [ __ ]
and i was just
talking to somebody yeah just talking
some [ __ ] yeah nah
i think that the records you making you
never expect to put out you never
i feel like a lot of records that end up
getting big are like those records
i got i got a video i got to drop to it
how's the video
nice well like a lot of i was surprised
i thought i thought she was gonna be
at her physical appearance or her
lyrical appearance on the song
no i'm like her energy okay oh she was
cool yes
she's beautiful too no she's beautiful
she's not as thick as i thought but
she's beautiful
you know what it's like this is not a
bad thought it's not i know it's not a
bad bunny you said that
because i put that together too yeah i
was like a show she's
beautiful yeah but i feel like she says
though but i'm like i thought she was
going to be like
big old ass but hey i'm good she's nice
though
thankful she probably doesn't have a
fake ass yeah yeah she's because
because you know most of these broads
out here got them fake asses
she she perfect shout out to mulatto
um why was it important to name the
album
dedicated it to to your boy g in the
name of g like
like i get in the name of g from in
there jesus
okay but you got your man next to you
you know what i'm saying like on the
cover like what what what was uh
it's basically like the like as far as
the cover
is like damn like he's still with me
he's on my back and i'm like you know
what i'm saying like
i don't know it's like i'm really
showing y'all like this in the name of g
like this is why y'all should follow me
if i got the sheep falling
nah i do think it's it's um obviously
man dude was a big deal in your life you
got to change the tattoo like
your album is named after him um do you
feel like you're still
like like are you still grieving his
loss or if you feel like you come to
peace with it
uh i gonna never come to peace
that's fair like some like you know how
they feeling like
you know that feeling that you get when
like um i probably
everybody had lost somebody of course of
course yeah but
it's always that reality feeling that
hits always hit you when you
when you think about a person like
actually like like
disappearing you feel me and it be like
that that
stuff feel it oh hit you right in the
stomach yeah always hit like that
damn man how has it been how long has it
been year and a half
three years [ __ ] that's crazy
do you feel like um
because you were saying before you got
locked up you guys were the hottest in
louisiana
do you kind of feel um i saw like it
on the album you said every time you see
his kid it makes you want to cry you
know what i'm saying
um do you feel like that responsibility
to kind of like bring his people along
with you make sure his people are
straight because you know he's not alone
he's not along with you to
enjoy the ride because right now you're
at the the biggest you've ever been you
know what i'm saying
i feel i i try to show as much love as i
can to
people like i mean basically like his
family i already had a relationship with
the people i had a relationship with i
ain't no y'all don't know
right right but what about his kid you
got a relationship with his kids yeah
like
i i got i got a somewhat relationship
with all the kids but
the others besides his son it'd be
harder to
to the other one the other baby mamas
yes that also all depends on how cool
the baby mama is
it's really like if i'm not giving no
money like it's like they don't want to
talk it's like some [ __ ] music so
oh [ __ ] yeah that's rough so you know
what i'm saying then the moment that you
don't get what they want
at that moment it's like you never did
nothing so that's crazy that's
unfortunate
i just got to like realization of like
last week like i'm just done with it
do you feel like that with a lot of
people in your life because i feel like
once you get
lately not like lately like which is
going to have been doing like some
really
like entertaining my more finding myself
like it's just like
i got to stop giving so much of myself
to people like people like me
i was talking to my own producer like
people like us
we work our whole life to make other
people happy so when we when we die we'd
be like the saddest
[ __ ] [ __ ] on earth you feel me
so then i ain't going out like that
damn that's some real [ __ ] i do feel
like you reach that successes
uh you become more of like a what can
you do for me and
it's like cause it got to the point
where like stuff don't make me happy
like yachts and all that [ __ ] it don't
make me happy like
what makes you happy just sitting
at home playing the games like this
i like to eat like just little [ __ ]
makes me happy but i wouldn't say happy
it's just like it makes me comfortable
i guess no i feel you it's like you
would rather chill and eat and play
i became that way with the club man
because you know i'm a club dj
but like you know it's been six seven
years since i've like
given the [ __ ] to go to a nightclub what
if i wasn't getting a bag there
when you think about like what is it
like i'll be in that i'm like really
like wow i'm here like
i don't want i don't drink liquor like
that it's nasty it's poison
everybody just around here looking
stupid everyone's standing around
10 000 sections like i'm i'm not like
why are you there
like unless you're picking up a bag
because that's why i'm not making no
money while
i'm not djing like why do i want to go
hang out i'd rather go i'd rather be
always paired no i hate being around a
lot of people
i'd rather go to a hole in the wall dive
bar then some people be standing at you
because you don't know if they're a fan
or not or they are or not
you just speak you feel me yeah
especially in your position bro
they're like do you want to do me
something yeah you'd be thinking
everything be like [ __ ] why don't you
stop looking at me
you say you don't drink um like that
i've been drinking like like we've been
in the house like i've been having like
some family come over we'll play drunk
ping pong [ __ ]
oh you tell my beer pong yeah but with
shots oh that's dangerous
so you're playing beer pong with shots
oh that's
that's rough that's rough with beer bro
we started all wrong we like
had 25 cuts on each side oh yeah
yeah we learned that was a rough night
we learned
what about do you participate do you
smoke weed do you do any sort of drugs
or anything like that
hey that's dope man did you ever have a
scent in your life where you
were you where you were like you know i
strung up doing lean or anything like
that yeah lean
i had lean on and lower tells i was on
the bed
what is that smaller
watson's so like it's like a is it like
a percocet
oh yeah see it's okay yeah it's opium
yeah so i was going bad so that [ __ ]
how long have you been off of that
because i know that shit's hard to kick
it's like you got to go through it no no
it's not
well depends on how hard how hard you go
playing if you just
a weak ass person mentally right so you
kicked it pretty easily
like it i would never like i need like i
used to just
overdo it you feel he was like really
recreationally [ __ ] with it yeah but
i was getting like i was
eight pills a day and like fought like
one time i i [ __ ] heat splashes and
feigning inside the barbecue one time
and getting full of lean
i caught all my charges up for the drink
so
he was on lean every time you got
arrested yeah because i used to just be
like just like a zombie no just you'd be
angry
that should make you angry and it gives
you a [ __ ] belly right
i heard that [ __ ] makes you gain weight
i think a lot of it too is like is all
the soda you drink with it people be
[ __ ]
drinking so much goddamn soda when
they're on i was small at all like 160 i
wasn't gaining no weight
so you was just leaned out catching
charges
was that what kind of made you like
realize like man i'm tripping like i'm
no i just went to jail and i i couldn't
get it so i just stopped
that's fine but but i always been a type
where like
i'll go like a couple days and like
detox myself
hey that's smart man a lot of people
ain't they can't say the same thing
yo what's up man boulette kev here
shouting out to the homies at odd socks
for sponsoring the bootleg cab podcast
and showing us love man
and let me tell you something we don't
take everyone's money
that's not true we'll take everyone's
money but donald trump's but with that
being said we [ __ ] with odd socks all
right um
i've been rocking odd socks for like
eight years now and um
man christmas time coming up make sure
you get you some odd socks
first of all let's talk about these
basics right here
these joints are the most comfortable
socks i've ever put on my feet all right
no design
no license but just crazy so make sure
you get some of those
all right then they got the nickelodeon
they got the uh
scarface they got tapatio they got wwe
how about chef from southpaw you know
what i'm saying whatever you need
shout out stone cold steve austin by the
way these are the socks that i wear when
i uh
drink pbr and yell at my wife uh anyway
um shout out to old dirty bastard too go
to oddssoxofficial.com
right now all right right now
go to oddssocksofficial.com use the
keyword bootleg kev
and you will receive 20 off at checkout
go do that
um the last time we talked we had
discussed
that boozy was you were related to boozy
and then i talked to boozy
and then i brought it up to him and he
was like
yeah i think he was like yeah my auntie
told me like you don't know that [ __ ]
you know i don't know you guys are
cousins or something right
and he was like i [ __ ] with him but
there's just some weird
there was like some weird beef [ __ ] i
don't know but that that neither of you
directly had with each other but it was
just some
i don't know have you guys had any sort
of
conversation we actually seen each other
you guys finally saw each other
and i and and mind you not only are you
related to him but he's also boozy and
and you're from baton rouge
and he's the god so talk about that
interaction how'd it go man
oh you're in the airport
and on atlanta about to fly out here
about to fly
and i seen him and i was like
yeah i got a highlighter you feel me of
course and we just we just ran it and
got some
just like clarification on like what it
was and what was it
um this is a lot of history between like
baton rouge and just like
people in general plus like tbg
you know him he used like i wouldn't say
he was tvg but
it was the same thing tvg embedded as
ant
was basically the same thing so it's a
lot of history with them and i wasn't
tbg
like me and g got started kind tvg in
like 2014.
so tbg was already a label that existed
yeah like it's been like you signed with
them in 2014.
i wouldn't sign it's just you guys
became a part of this yeah and so
there was a split between badass and tbg
i'm assuming
way before way before we came and got
involved i got yous
yeah like like we probably was the last
ones they ever like
become tvg like even on the dude
um contrail he was a tvg before us
so that was really it it was like some
[ __ ] that you really
weren't a part of yeah so you guys are
solid
no good do you i mean i'm assuming that
doing a record together might be
out of the question still maybe i've
been sending it he'd have to work that
out with the you could i mean
no i sent him a record
hey man that'd be crazy
the last time we talked to uh and things
have escalated since then but you
you had said essentially that you'd be
open to working with young boy
and then this video dropped on his
instagram where he was talking
crazy i was like
there's just certain things you don't
say and the way he was talking
and i feel like he does that a lot yeah
and obviously he's the number one
streaming artist
right now in the world all right very
talented guy but i do feel like
he is habitually disrespectful to the
point where it's like
almost there's no coming back from the
level of disrespect he displays online
sometimes
yeah i saw your reply uh
is there an end to that
situation that doesn't involve any
i don't know what's happened i don't
know you know like you said
you lost your partner i lost my partner
only difference is you ain't post them
i don't know if that was for him it's
just a soul but that by the way fireline
love that line but what i'm saying is
i'm not
saying anything has happened or hasn't
happened what i'm saying is is there any
sort of
resolution or are you open to any sort
of resolution that does not involve
any more just ignorant [ __ ] i don't have
no problem with him i was gonna say
you seem like the nicest guy and then
like with that that whole situation like
i mean he was angry he just like talking
about digging up your dead homies i'm
like bro that's
there's certain things it's like
i didn't do so much stuff in life that
you know what i'm saying like
i know who i am so
that that that that role when you got to
prove yourself you got to get like
it it's a few things it's like you
really can't
barely make me angry to where i'm going
to show that i'm angry
you feel me like oh
it's just oh no like i don't know
that wasn't in the proof nobody yeah i
feel like you you're comfortable in your
own skin
yeah definitely you haven't i don't feel
like i've ever
like your come up did not to me
represent you
trolling on the internet doing that
because i don't have to like i don't i
don't
i don't got to get on my instagram point
guns
no you've not no 100 i don't i don't
gotta
i kill your mama and all that like like
people know who i am
they know what i and they know what it
would do like i'm i'm good
i'm i'm in a whole different lane in
life not like
i'm not when you saw that though did
that did that make you angry or did you
just choose because i mean
it seemed like your your reaction wasn't
like you know it was kind of
it was funny it was kind of like bro
like come on bro no he was like really
angry like
he was pissed yo when that [ __ ]
began turnt up
i'd be like is he on like what is going
on like and someone take his phone
but did it you didn't react angrily like
you reacted kind of more lighthearted
obviously you talked about you know
about the boy's father no i'm just
saying if if i if if
i wanted to be an angry person and i
like you know what i'm saying like it's
a dirty person like well listen the last
time we talked you were like i'd be open
to working with him
i would i still would i don't i i'm a
business person like i don't have
especially i don't have nothing against
him like he never did me nothing
never did nothing nobody around me was
the original
the origin of the issue with your man g
originally
um i really don't know
like i was listening when i was in jail
right
yeah everybody was good
just so everybody know give them the
timeline from what year to what year
were you in jail the two and a half
years two thousand the first day of 2016
all the way to the middle of twenty may
2018. okay
so i'm really going like a little deep
with you already i appreciate it
but i when i went to jail all of us are
good right
yeah but he had left tvg
when i was in jail people
i i don't know the 4k trade [ __ ] came
from all right
it was nba anybody came to nba
they come on my line we eat together we
straight you know what i'm saying it was
like
i think the dude the dude um
i really don't i'm really getting deep
with you like the dude
[ __ ] um like i don't know is it like
when they
bbgs all that like soft side like right
straight ain't nobody
ain't no up fred i wanna do fredo's
something like
that then you you get out of jail and
then [ __ ] goes up
i get out of jail like i'm calling
people like what up [ __ ] like
[ __ ] like
[ __ ] calling me hanging up and [ __ ]
like damn
next week on my op like i'm like wait so
he was calling you hanging out no no
no not him there's other people yeah
just like it's just like people like
like fool we were just in jail a couple
months ago we was
making a hookup together hanging out
yeah like making some spread like [ __ ]
damn like you know what i'm saying
and then always be [ __ ] me up cause
like damn y'all could have did me
something
like that you would have been
comfortable you let your guard down
around these guys
right damn and you guys have never had a
conversation together you and
and and young boys since since you got
out of jail
have you guys had any sort of dialogue
or
no but you're open to it oh yeah
i don't have no problem with this dude
you're bigger than a lot of people man
it's more social media like that's what
it feels like like
if you ain't you ain't giving me no you
need no people nothing like this
hey man that's the same thing i told uh
emily chop when i first met him
i was like yo man you gotta chill out on
that internet [ __ ] bro
yeah and every time i seen him since
then he's been growing as a you know he
said people forget that dude's a kid
you were just with him the other night
right yeah like people don't realize
like he's not even 18.
but i would tell him you know like yo
the internet [ __ ] bro like chill like
like you're a good kid yeah i said like
this is like
it is dope to see his growth but i feel
like like you said you're so comfortable
in your own skin and then like i'm not
about to
put my myself at risk doing this
instagram
fighting gangsta ass [ __ ] then the
cops got
to get on here and tell you i would do
you something like
why you feeling like i like food i
really just
was fighting 40 years i like i really
didn't know if i was coming home
you feel me like almost like
i didn't actually slept next to people
who actually have life not people who
who might get it or not like i've been
next to these people who are not coming
home
like and that's that's like a lot of
people that go to the gym they get out
they go out and get out but they never
been
there they never got time and had to
really
down ain't gonna [ __ ] my paperwork up
nah they trying to make me do a flat
seven like
at first they had my paperwork [ __ ] up
if i have a lawyer i'd be still
just cause they [ __ ] up my menace wow
feeling like just like [ __ ] like and
imagine how many times that [ __ ] just
happens
so people who just supposed to be home
right right
that's just crazy i'm just making my
money i'm doing my thing like
now like you said man i think um
the the the internet beef and [ __ ] is
corny like if it's beef it ain't gonna
be on the internet
and that's you know i mean maybe i'm
just old but
that seems kind of the way you know
hip-hop is going and it's unfortunate to
see
um who's some artists who we we
first of all we're talking about the
double xl freshman cover and i thought
you should have
been considered for that slot one of
them um
we were also talking about how bad a lot
of the freestyles were
we won't say whose freestyles were
shitty but there were some really bad
ones
um i'll just say little kids freestyle
was really bad
he didn't say it i said it um
but um some of the people on there
definitely deserve to be on there but
who who are some of the younger artists
um that you feel like you know
kind of like deserving of that slot that
maybe didn't catch it or somebody who
you're just a fan of that's coming
up right now um one person i definitely
know should have been on that with
vaughn
like as far as numbers and growth and
just
doing this thing like fun we're supposed
to be on it i don't know
how he didn't um it's called billy
footage
i'm sorry he's trying to put the thing
on the screen right here so yeah yeah
vaughn definitely
von
though what do i just like i'm trying to
think of like anybody else could like
i'll be getting i'll be really
forgetting people
have you heard uh blast from l.a blast
oh you gotta [ __ ] with him he's crazy i
also feel like the
the blue kid is dope young blues though
there's some
blue vandross the kid from uh where's
the [ __ ] is he from we just had him
he's from alabama yeah yeah he had went
to the restaurant
i don't know yeah he got a restaurant
yeah shout out to him what
are you um now you got some money you
know you got your head on straight are
you
uh doing the right things with your
bread are you trying to invest you
yeah i just made me i just started a
management company
should we start managing artists do you
feel like that's a hard thing to do
as a as an artist or is it easy because
i'm not gonna be
personally in it you just got your
people running yeah like i'm i just look
over like
what songs like they need to drop at
that point in time maybe like a label
type
situation yeah but it's more like i'm
like
like like yoshi like i don't know you
probably haven't heard of him yet but
it's
like artists i'm working on right now he
got a little independent deal he about
to do
but can you help him manage yeah but
like
basically like when we started off i
told him i was like fool
all right i'm gonna play for videos and
[ __ ] like that show me you serious
though
show me you can you know what i'm saying
cause he just thought like he made his
like one
one song so you know i did that and then
like i put it to where he gonna
he make every dime off every play he
ever get you feel me
so like he grows he's getting better and
better and like nahi
you know what i'm saying so i rather
like start off with people i
we do this 50 50 thing i paid i paid for
your stuff
one day i make my money back you know
what i'm saying but as long as you grow
for you making money
you know what i'm saying we're going
somewhere instead of me just giving you
1500 grand
and hoping that you and then sign your
life to me yeah now you now you
not making no money and you you going
red you feel me yeah because
starting off in the red you're right hey
that's crazy you say that man cause
cause i feel like that's the biggest one
of the biggest
mistakes artists make is what you just
said and that's
taking that quick advance cause like you
said
you start off in the red you got to make
that [ __ ] back twice over yeah but
it's like different strokes from
different folks though no you're right
some people like
you're right yeah i said basically like
hey i feel like you just based
everything off your situation and what
makes you comfortable at that moment you
know what i'm saying how has the um
have you like have you noticed the
difference
working with dev jam and how has your
experience been being with dev jam has
it been a positive one has it been kind
of me
positive i mean by work still work the
same like
like do you feel like they added
anything to what you're doing
yeah like what though
marketing for show um
a few connections get me in like some
buildings that i wouldn't be a part of
like
i probably wouldn't be on the bootleg
cabin here so honestly i didn't know you
were on deaf channel
i was just reaching out to you bro i had
only been on death jam when i came back
yeah
but what i'm saying is i was me and you
were dming each other for a while
i dm'd you like six seven months maybe
maybe three four months before you came
by
and i didn't know you're on def jam so
you would have been you would have been
on the show either way
i'm saying beforehand no for sure for
sure no i think i think like i think
with labels you know they just really
gotta start to really
they gotta really start with younger
artists like you
they really gotta start to show people
why why they should sign
like they were like besides like you
said you know a few connections like i
feel like you're
you could do so much of that [ __ ] on
your own like any of the features on
your album
they probably you you probably could
have got the mulatto and the kevin gate
you definitely could have got the kevin
gates feature
i mean i mean i basically did you know
but not mulatto the label did though i'm
tripping
[ __ ] they did that way why do you think
um
baton rouge is first of all i don't be
hard upon working with people like that
though because i've noticed
if i like your music out like i don't
care if you got ten thousand followers i
will write you and be like oh [ __ ] hard
that's fine and then like people will be
like one reply
or you know what i'm saying and then
like a couple months down the road
when they when they bugged on they asked
me for a feature like
but i'm one of them people like i'd have
made my own foundation i ain't
had to exit everybody for future so
that's why my [ __ ] just gonna keep on
climbing because i'm not
ron has been chasing features you know
what i'm saying you know some artists
they need that feature to kind of
i mean like you said it's kind of like
different struggles they need to be
babysitted they need a daddy
yeah i think i think like a feature can
help
because it can bring those fans to your
[ __ ] and if your [ __ ] is dope they're
gonna stick around and become your fans
like the most hated like it's like show
a lot of people that like i'm in hell
right a lot of people don't know i think
it did like 8 000 some copies right
but my project got like almost 200
million string you know
it was also a mixtape yeah and by the
way
it wasn't like you know you know
satellite was there
there's no no it sounds like an album
but what i'm saying is
this is your second project since the
[ __ ] really since
kind of since the pandemic i mean right
before the pandemic you dropped one but
what i'm saying is like
i feel like
they haven't impacted us on your radio
yet like you know what i mean
i feel like this was just based off of
you know
you and by the way 8 000 is not it's not
it's not a bad number like you said the
amount of streams you're getting is
crazy
and then this one like so a couple more
thousand did like ten thousand so
i i'm doing i'm showing growth you're
feeling me but the good thing about it
is like
it's me and it's my foundation you know
what i'm saying
i'm not on this [ __ ] [ __ ]
basing my whole project off of a verse
from
being you know what i'm saying i'm not
basing my project off that like that's
why i dropped the gates
video i dropped it before my project
came out because i don't want
i didn't want that to be the focus point
of my project
you feel me i was gonna ask you about
baton rouge um
two two two in a question one what is it
about baton rouge that you think is kind
of the center of rap right now
because it is it's like baton rouge
memphis oh
outside of like atlanta you know i think
baton rouge is it at the moment
i'll say um for one our beats
i beat selection well a lot of a lot of
people can't pick beats sometimes
but most of the top artists from
louisiana and baton rouge
at this moment we got we know how to
pick beats
um we know that just you know i'm saying
we know that vibe you feel me
and it's such a distinct difference
between like
new orleans and baton rouge like yeah
with two different slangs two different
like sonically everything's different
yeah oh yeah cause
oh no yeah noah got a whole complete
different sound and be all
like
it's kind of hard to explain like you
know they used to call it [ __ ] city
xps [ __ ]
new orleans was on heroin and [ __ ] like
so it's it's like it's just
do two different worlds one one city on
this drug the other city on that drug
one city's
[ __ ] the other city is falling asleep
[Laughter]
no that's crazy no because you're right
i remember hearing about new orleans and
the heroin issues in new orleans two
different worlds
bg had a bad heroin problem you know
what i'm saying freebie no like like
danny all the gangsters all
all the rich [ __ ] in all the games has
been on h like ben
it's just been a thing they just do it
quietly yeah they got like they got they
got big orders from louisiana
right now each that are still like
shooting up
nah i'm not shooting that they're
probably smoking them snorting it yeah
i don't know why they wait till they get
rich
damn that's terrible whatever i'd say
it's just like i don't know they'd be
hurt deep inside you know what i'm
saying
man that sucks man heroin
but you know what if you think i mean it
goes hand in hand with the lean and the
and the perks and the in the oxies no
that's a different world
but what i'm saying is it's a lot more
serious of a world yeah like
what i'm saying is like you just feel
like you got to put it up your nose
like it's just or shoot it up yes that's
the next level difference
i'm just saying their downers their
opiates like
you're not just chasing the high no more
you should you see deeper [ __ ] going on
some deep [ __ ] because usually you do
heroin because you can't afford the
perks no more
and the heroin bruh you could get some
black tar heroin
so that's [ __ ] but i'm saying man
people playing most people who end up on
heroin now
is because they end up [ __ ] up off the
pills and they and and they're chasing
the same height for the pills
what nah nah at least people like but
listen i i i'm very close
i know but it's different worlds right
right right it's different worlds and
reasons you feel me
no heroin is serious when you get into
that [ __ ] it's like yeah i know it's
like some people just want to get [ __ ]
up but something like
like iowa right h is like
for good like you're not about getting
nothing under 150 to to fit that line
damn yeah you know what i'm saying it's
it's a whole different world
with us that's crazy ain't no fit that
all online and all that [ __ ] that's
that's that's that [ __ ] that's about to
kill you as soon as you eat it oh for
sure
and then you say baton rouge back in the
day you should be known for ecstasy
yeah yeah sure man that's crazy yeah
i've drove through baton rouge a couple
of times and it was like
i just feel like louisiana in general
there's just so it just it just feels
like like the epic
it just feels like you know you'd be
seeing [ __ ] on on tv right like you'd be
like i see new orleans on tv and then
you go there and you're like this [ __ ]
is like it just feels like so cultured
like
everything is old the buildings are from
the [ __ ]
and then when we drove through baton
rouge and we stopped and hate like it
was just like yeah this [ __ ] is
this [ __ ] is ill like it just you could
feel it in the air like there's
something special about louisiana bro
like
i don't know if it's the cajun [ __ ] or
you know it's it's something special
about it and then
even like just food wise
some of the best food in america bro
definitely best food
you're like crawfish and
what's the po boys and is the food
different
from baton rouge to new orleans or is it
pretty much kind of consistent
oh it's
[Music]
oh i see we got lip lit differences but
it's basically saying are you um this is
like the mains like the main thing is
the seasoning
so all is using like that what is what
is what is the go-to seasoning for you
what is it yo tony sash's creole
seasoning is that something you can get
anywhere or you got to get it over there
you gotta
get not um like when dixon has stuff be
having a certain
i miss winn-dixie man i live in florida
when dixie was so cheap
do they have publix in louisiana no that
you know
in florida what about wawa's yeah
bro wawa's i
man listen bro when i lived in florida
they had publix and wild wilds you go to
wawa's and get you a [ __ ] sandwich at
three in the morning at a gas station
and that [ __ ] would be smacking i've
never heard of this
that [ __ ] is are you uh besides the
deluxe edition do you plan on dropping
any other projects uh
in before the end of the year um i
probably i don't really like the
holidays i'll probably wait till january
so january but you'll get the we'll get
the deluxe before
before the holidays right yeah like next
couple weeks
who you who you got on the deluxe
oh no i don't know well listen i would
just like to put this in the air i don't
know i might not put nobody on i don't
know
i would like to just throw this out
there i think it would be
so big to
one day to have the boozy fredo bang
and it'd be a young boy song
i think that would make that would be
like the the baton rouge
[ __ ] posse cut of all time
no chances of that happening probably
never but you know what i'm saying
i'm just speaking it into existence you
know what i'm saying
that'd be nice or you and boozy do like
a [ __ ] you know family ties [ __ ]
group album you know what i'm saying
that should be crazy
uh anyway look man i appreciate you for
[Laughter]
appreciate you for checking in um the
album is out
it's fire um i think too man
you're really getting on your [ __ ] on
your rap and [ __ ] like i feel like
you've improved a lot
yeah yeah i had like that's why like i'm
getting better because like
a lot of my [ __ ] was too much singing i
don't know i've been trying to rap more
well i mean i i i'm not i'm really
specific
like i don't i don't consider myself a
rapper i'm i'm more of a creator yeah
but i'm saying like i feel like you
really improved like at least you know
to me
just on the rapping side just on this
project i was like oh i see he's
you know improving yeah and that's all
you can ask for you know what i'm saying
growth improvement all that [ __ ] um
anything else you want to want to plug
man
want to throw your gamer tag out there i
don't know but
you don't remember your gamertag
damn well if you see this guy online
run because he's got a pc and it's got a
half a second jump on everybody who's
got a playstation
hey shots headshots gulags and all that
send you straight to the gulag that's
that's what happens when you die right
yeah yeah okay oh yeah
bro sign me up with some tony hawk or 2k
bro
anyway my g appreciate you brother
always man appreciate